to begin with you start by
doing what we call doing affirmations
and that is making positive statements
about your life
that
are positive
and you do them deliberately you might
do them in the morning you might do them
at noon you might do them at night
you might do them you know
twice a day or whatever but you do this
and you let this become a habit
and as you start to do them
things will begin to change maybe on a
very small level i call it getting the
green lights from the parking places i
mean they're not huge things in your
life they can be very nice when you get
three green lights in a row
and you're in a hurry
doing an affirmation is either writing
it down writing it on the wall or the
mirror or using a
you know just saying it what i like
people to do is to stand in front of a
mirror and do their affirmations
because there's something very powerful
about looking in your own eyes
and getting
and accepting yourself or noticing that
you reject yourself when you're saying
something positive about yourself
so that would be a very beginning way to
start
say in the morning you get up in the
morning you go to the mirror and this is
a big one and it's hard for lots of
people
but you look in the mirror and i say and
say i love you i really really love you
and to begin with that can be so hard
for people because they think of all the
things that they think are wrong with
them but if you can start your day
saying that it's very powerful
remember i'd like to think the universe
is listening to everything you say and
everything you think and saying okay you
can get that
so then it starts to bring you in and
bring things into you and i know this
sounds far-fetched but it's amazing how
it works
if you do a good general positive
statement for yourself
the universe will figure out how to
manifest that
how to bring that about in your life
so things could happen that you wouldn't
expect at all
but they will happen
if you think of doing your positive
affirmations is like planting a seed in
the ground it's not necessarily true at
the moment but it is something you want
to have be true
so you put the seed in
and you
you plant a seed and you expect it to
grow
or you maybe plant three seeds just in
case you expect them to grow and you
don't wait two days and then dig in the
earth and say what's happening what's
happening you expect that thing to grow
because you know there's a law and a
process
and the seed will grow if it is in the
right soil and it has the right amount
of moisture
making it really a habit
and doing it every day
doing something every morning when you
wake up that's a really good time and
another good time is when you go to
sleep at night wanna be happy build a
life not just a business hey it's evan
carmichael and this channel was created
to help you overcome the number one
challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you two you've got
michael jordan level genius at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn how you can attract
better things into your life enjoy
rule number two open yourself to the
possibility for all of us you know and
uh we've been conditioned you know i
mean you were very fortunate because you
you had a
a childhood where
you were
mind was opened and you were opened and
your heart was opened and that's the
biggest biggest thing
is to open yourself to the possibility
that everything isn't the way it appears
to be
and so even if you can just open
yourself to that possibility just for a
moment you can pick up at all the next
day you can take it all with you the
next day that it's all real and
everything that you're seeing but if you
just for a moment open to the
possibility that things might not be the
way that you think they are
then you have the greatest opportunity
to really discover something incredible
how incredible you are rule number three
move into a state of being with dr joe
dispenza if the person's doing the
vision board and they're saying when i
get my new car i get my new house i get
my new relationship
then i'm gonna feel so great
now that well then they're back to the
program waiting for it to happen for
them to feel the emotion they're
believing their outer world has to
change in order for them to feel better
there's there's no
effect of drawing the experience to you
with that way
so
the person has to use those tools
to get them into the emotional state
for them to feel like it's already
happened now think about this
if you get up from
a creative process
and you feel grateful
you feel a love for life you feel a joy
for existence
you feel a passion
to
for the moment
uh
you will not be looking for your future
because you'll feel like it's already
happened
it's the moment that we start feeling
those self-limiting emotions that we
feel separation and then we start
looking for it again well then if you're
waiting you're not creating you're
you're in separation again so then yeah
so then
whatever it takes for you to move into a
state of being and what is a state of
being
thoughts are the vocabulary of the brain
feelings are the vocabulary of your body
how you think and how you feel creates
your state of being so then if you wake
up in the morning and you
come come back to your senses with a
clean slate and you say i don't feel
anything you say well let me start
thinking about all the problems in my
life well all those problems are
connected to different people or
different objects of things at different
times and places the moment you remember
your problems a memory is a record of
the past you're thinking in the past
every one of those problems has an
emotion associated with them so all of a
sudden you start feeling unhappy you
start feeling bitter you start feeling
frustrated so now your body's in the
past so then most people then
create a state of being that's connected
to their past and if they're in the
familiar past
then they are going to crave the
predictable future and they're going to
fall back into routine
so then
we want people then to get very clear on
that vision of their future however they
do it and begin to combine that clear
intention with an elevated emotion and
the stronger the emotion they feel
from the vision they're creating the
more altered they feel inside of them
the more they're going to pay attention
to the pictures in their mind and now
they're remembering their future and
biologically it's exactly the same as
remembering your past in fact if you're
not being defined by a vision in the
future it means you're making your past
more real than your future you're
falling in love with your past you're
more in love with your past than you are
with your future that you're believing
in your past more than you're believing
in your future when you get to that
moment
where you have that feeling
that's your compass
because that feeling is going to drive
your behaviors it's going to drive more
of those thoughts and when you feel that
feeling and it's visceral
no person
no thing no experience will stand in the
way between you and that vision and and
you will be initiated in by the universe
into wealth you will be initiated into
health you'll be initiated into freedom
those people all those people that have
healed themselves of all those different
health conditions
they are so humble
and so happy
and they feel so great
that they would never trade this feeling
because of what you thought of them they
they've they've left that program behind
a long time ago they actually don't care
how you think of them they they actually
are so happy with themselves
that they're no longer dependent on
anything outside of them now i think
that's a really important moment because
that's the moment we give people
permission in our lives to do the same
right and i think that more and more
people are beginning to figure that out
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number four use your
imagination with bob proctor i set a
goal in 1973
i set a goal that i was going to build a
company and upgrade all over the world
i had
left the night galconet corporation
and decided that i was going to do this
because i didn't agree with the way they
were doing it
people weren't really learning it fast
enough
they wouldn't get involved in the
reputation we were selling recordings
but the recordings weren't working
because the people didn't understand how
to use them
so i decided i would leave and start my
own company
and i wrote down i'd build a company and
operate all over the world i got a call
last night from mikey about nine o'clock
something like that
and then she told me
that we were now
in every country in the world
now think of
that we had a broadcast going on here at
10 o'clock this morning
some of you'd be familiar with it some
of you may have been on it
and
that broadcast had attracted thousands
literally thousands of people
from every country in the world
the goal was reached
that move
meant this is really accurate today
we're only limited by weakness of
attention and poverty of imagination
well my imagination was pretty well
exercised i don't have any difficulty
building huge ideas in my mind and just
figuring out how to do it
now stay with me here
the thing that's stopping you
from taking the risk that you want to
take
is called a terror barrier
the way i'm going to explain this to you
i come up with sitting in a restaurant i
remember it was at a holiday inn
restaurant
it was at dixie and uh just south of the
401 highway
in toronto
a man asked me if i would meet with him
he had a problem
and i was going to show him how he could
solve the problem
and he explained it so i took a pen and
some paper and what i'm going to show
you here is essentially what i showed
him
now look at this for a moment
there is the process you go through
when you're in a risk-taking vibration
you go from bondage
to reason
to the terror barrier and then to
freedom
you go from bondage
to reason
to the terror barrier
and then to freedom rule number five
connect to your guide with gabby
bernstein i write in the book about how
i'm gonna push the metaphysical envelope
and i'm going to go to places i haven't
gone before and i never went there
before because i didn't want to alienate
my reader and i had a lot of new seekers
that were joining me on this journey but
i feel right now that people are
completely ready for this conversation
and they can take it or leave it yeah
and make it their own yeah and my
beliefs do not have to be theirs that's
a really important point that whatever
we believe when we think about a higher
power spiritual presence is what we
believe and all that matters is that you
believe it not that someone said it's
this or that it's it's it's it may be a
religious spiritual belief system it may
be a belief system from your childhood
maybe something that you read in a book
that resonated with you you decide
that's the beautiful thing about being
on a spiritual path but what i share is
what i believe to be true about what it
means to connect to the voice of our
higher self our inner guidance system
and our inner wisdom versus what it
means to rely on a guide or a angel or a
deceased family member uh or a loved one
and so i believe we all have these two
this t we all have a team of of guides
of spiritual guides that work on our
behalf all the time and what they're
there for is often to guide be a bridge
for our thoughts so when our thoughts
are in those low vibrations if we pray
to a guide or we pray to god or we pray
to an angel we can say thank you for for
bridging my thought from this low
vibrational fear-based belief system to
a higher vibe and the way that they
would do that maybe by putting a book in
front of you or guiding you to an
episode of marietv that is going to just
change your mind so guides work through
the internet and books and people and
and and your and your subconscious and
so you're gonna maybe when you have
those moments where you're like i have
this sense that i need to to watch that
episode of marietv right now maybe
somebody watching just got the hit yeah
that could have been your guide just
giving you that boost of inspiration
watch that watch that because that's
going to change you and so don't
underestimate those moments of
synchronicity because there's support
that's leading you in those
synchronistic moments and so the more
that we align with our spiritual belief
systems and the more we
allow ourselves to accept that it's good
to feel good and the more we use things
like the emotional guidance scale or the
choose again method or any of the
methods in this book the better we feel
and the better we feel the more we can
hear the guidance that we're receiving
the guidance is always there but we
block it we cut it off and so we can
open up to that guidance rule number six
be appreciative with ken honda once you
start appreciating your life shifts too
for example one of the readers on my
book
she was a single mom
with a low paying job she was working as
a secretary and then she came to me and
she used to complain about
her low paying job but after reading my
book she
changed her attitude and she started
appreciating about life and boss and and
she realized that she didn't have a
college degree
but she got she was hired as a secretary
so that's a big reason to appreciate her
boss
before she was office complaining about
him
and i think the feeling really probably
came across to his uh her boss and she
got a big raise uh in a few weeks
so once you start appreciating i i've
heard so many stories i can even write
few books on this
once you start appreciating your boss
your clients
they appreciate you back so uh in my 20s
the reason why i i was successful was i
was a little uh unique
in so many different different things
for example when i was doing accounting
consulting i divided my uh clients to
two groups one i do regular job the
other i always bring something whenever
i got to meet them just a herb tea
japanese tea like a book or just not
super expensive
so in six months i got so many referrals
from the the gift giving groups you know
i didn't ask for any clients right but
they gave me uh so many referrals and
the second you know a group uh not so
much so
i re i recommend everybody to start
giving more uh something a little extra
nuts like 30 more
but something to to show appreciation
and
uh it doesn't really matter if you're
florist or cleaners or
business lawyers or a dentist if you
start giving something you get more so
this is the law i think if you give more
um you receive more and then there is
one more extra reason to appreciate
about so you you your life would shift
so your whole energy would be so
different and so content and i think
people want to do business with happier
people you know people don't want to go
with people who are very depressed
so the people with the radiance of
appreciation often attracts
more people and more opportunities so
this is not a new age or a spiritual
thing it's a practice to to
um to appreciate more so what you
appreciate appreciates and i think it's
it's so simple so start appreciating
about money is the first step and then
second step is start appreciating what
you have and rule number seven the last
one before some very special bonus clips
is exercise your bravery with robin
sharma it is stunning how far you get
when you say here's my vision i will
take a bullet for it martin luther king
jr said until you have discovered
something you are willing to die for
you're not fit to live are you so
emotionally visually invested in your
vision for the rest of your life in your
business in your health in your humanity
in your giving in your family in your
service to the world that no matter what
happens
you would take a bullet for it
you know what made apple apple
most tech companies have a vision for
their products and services
and every single time they encounter a
constraint
they dilute their vision
so eventually the vision means nothing
am i making sense here i'm just curious
steve jobs said six weeks before the
apple iphone shipped i want a type of
glass
on that screen so that the users
so loved the icons on the iphone screen
they would want to
lick the screen
and steve jobs was told
that does not exist and yet six weeks
before the iphone iphone shipped
i believe corning made the glass he got
the job done why because he knew how to
lead
and so my point is think about grit
don't dilute your vision when you get
laughed at don't dilute your vision
when you stumble don't dilute your
vision when you feel scared
don't dilute your vision
when you get heartbroken don't dilute
your vision
when you're on the top of the mountain
and everyone's saying your best don't
dilute your vision when you're in the
valley of pain and darkness and
frustration and you feel like giving up
don't dilute your vision and don't just
do it for yourself do it for your family
do it for your team do it for your
customers do it for what it makes up the
world because you're one of the rare
souls who didn't listen to the voice of
their fear instead you exercise the
bravery to roll up your sleeves and get
the job done examples
stephen king
we pedestal him now
first book terry rejected 30 times
any good vision will be ridiculed
here's the thing you've got pages of
ideas today you're going to go home
you're going to share them even with
your loved ones they're going to laugh
and mock you
well intentioned as they are
how many people in this room will give
up on the way you feel with me right now
because you actually
sell yourself on listening to what
they're saying
he threw it into the trash
his wife resurrected it
now a legendary author probably one of
the top five selling authors in the
world grit
grit
did you know vincent van gogh never sold
more than a handful of paintings in the
course of his lifetime
he went starving his paintings are
selling for hundreds of millions of
dollars
he didn't do it for the money great
monuments the sistine chapel wasn't done
for the money
the theory of relativity wasn't done for
the money apple wasn't done for the
money amazon wasn't done for the money
nations being freed wasn't done for the
money it was done for leadership
he only sold a few paint one painting he
often went starving but he completed 800
works because he was a craftsman
he was doing it for who he became what
he became he was doing it to produce and
birth art out into the world
now his paintings are revered as
masterpieces
jk rowling single mother on welfare in a
rat infested flat
harry potter rejected this boy wizard
story because it was a disruptive idea
to the industry rejected by nine
publishers any good vision will be
misunderstood otherwise it is not a good
vision
450 million plus copies sold worthwhile
but the best example i can offer you on
grant is this gentleman
august 1 1976
the
second turn in the german grand prix
nikki lauda lost control and he hit a
wall he spent almost 60 seconds in 450
degree heat trapped into his car
the damage to his body was so severe
they said when we looked at his face
it's like his face was melting off
they rushed him to the hospital
the doctor saw nikki laudo come in
they said call the priest we need to
administer last rites
nikki lauter himself said you know i
felt like i was going to fall asleep but
something deep within me said this would
not be an ordinary type of sleep i need
to do whatever it takes to stay awake
he said you know i knew it was bad when
my wife showed up and she fainted
six weeks
later
he put on bandages over his face
and he put on a helmet and he placed
fourth in the italian grand prix
you need to create an environment of
excellence excellence most people's
environments
are not excellent the people around you
the the videos that you watch the things
that are on your wall the voices that
are in your head you have these moments
that are bold that are courageous that
make you feel unstoppable and you can do
anything
and then you fall back down because the
environment is the thing that's keeping
you small it takes a giant effort to
overcome your environment you definitely
can it's definitely possible tons of
people are doing it but it takes that
giant effort to say i don't want to stay
stuck here
most people stay stuck most people make
minimal minimal minimal improvements in
their life year over year
and if you don't want to stay where you
are right now fast forward to one year
from today
you don't want to stay stuck you want to
be in a different place could actually
be physically moving but a different
place in terms of your finances in terms
of your purpose in terms of how much
you're given and caring and sharing and
the life that you want to build you want
to be somewhere totally different like
today this is not acceptable anymore i
accept that this is where i am right now
but where i end up is not going to be
the same spot as where i am right now
right if that's your commitment the
biggest shift that will help you get
from where you are now to where you want
to be is creating that environment of
excellence what's the fastest way to
learn a language what's the fastest way
to learn japanese well it's to go to
japan sure you can read some books and
and you can hire a tutor and
the more intense it becomes the more
you're actually living it
the faster you're gonna pick it up
so if you want to develop the mindset of
the high achiever if you want to become
that person know the people that you
look up to the the whoever of the world
like i want to be the next whoever
perfect that person the more you hang
around with them
the more it's going to rub off on you
how they think because how they think
how they act how they behave how they
see the world is very different
than how you see it right now and how
the people around you definitely see the
world right now
so how do you do it how do you start to
become it well i look at what i'm doing
and this was one of my biggest
challenges when i was getting started
and honestly still in like i think the
biggest problem in the world is a lack
of belief
i'm trying to solve the world's biggest
problem people don't believe in
themselves enough i don't you don't
oprah doesn't people don't believe in
themselves enough for the next level so
how do you start to believe in yourself
more the thing that helped me the most
was to have these successful people
around me constantly
and so i want to share a few tactics
that i think can really help you
that has really helped me as being the
shy introverted kid who never wanted to
be in front of a camera and was making
300 bucks a month and
quit on my business partner and thought
life was over right to now here and it's
taken me 20 years to get here so
hopefully we can shorten that path for
you if you actually follow some of the
advice in this video
so step number one how do we create that
environment of excellence
what you feed into your brain really
really really matters
so figure out how you love to learn for
me it's videos i like to see things i
need to be visual if that's you
then you need to have a way to have
those videos coming into your life every
day
it could be part of your morning routine
that's why i make this channel part of
your morning routine subscribe to the
channel every morning every weekday we
got a new video out there for you to
give you the shot of entspresso to help
you but if it's not my channel it's some
other channel one of my other channels
subscribe to the channels that make you
feel bold powerful unstoppable give you
hope give you belief in yourself
and then watch that video every day or
listen to that podcast every day or read
that book every day the trick is it
can't be the same book or the the one
video because that one video on repeat
is going to lose its effectiveness right
you know it
you watch your video get you all fired
up and then you watch it again the next
day and it's not as like oh what
happened i don't feel as good you watch
the next day and the feeling is gone so
you can't just read the same book over
and over watch the same video over and
over and over again the key is to find a
consistent source so if you love this
channel or you love this video i'm
making other videos just like this
that you can subscribe to if you'd like
an author go find their other books or
go find the people that inspire them so
that you can read something every day if
you'd like a podcast go find other
podcasts like them so you have something
every day so you you are
manipulating what comes in your head
with intention now
with intention so you're not just
scrolling through things like i am going
to watch one of these videos every day
to slowly shift myself forward because
it'll happen if you love elon musk and
you watch elon musk every day what will
happen is slowly day by day you will
start to think like elon musk it will
happen he will pull you forward you will
start to see the big difference in how
he thinks versus how the people around
you think versus how you think right now
and he will give you more courage and
more boldness and more
a sense of hope and purpose that you can
do it too you'll start to think more
like him
so be careful who you pick and maybe you
don't like elon musk maybe you like
kanye west or oprah winfrey or whoever
but the more you're around that person
the more you will start to think like
that so you want to put that as part of
your daily routine that every day
because yesterday was a different day
you might have been fired up bold
motivated great but today's today's a
new day
the motivation you had yesterday is
nowhere near what it is right now when
you wake up
right you get the best day of all time
you wake up the next day and it's gone
so how do you keep the consistency the
routine
tell yourself i'm going to watch a video
even when i don't want to even when i
feel low energy even when right all the
excuses we come up with i'm going to
watch a video to get myself into the
state i need to get into because i want
to follow i want to follow my dreams i
don't want to be stuck here anymore most
people number one they get up in the
morning they check their cell phone they
check their text their whatsapp their
facebook they post something on facebook
drive to work the same way do the same
thing so they're a program they've
actually lost their free will to the
program wow so if you start your day
and you start your day with this simple
question
what is the greatest ideal of myself
that i can be today you ask yourself
that question now listen your body's
going to go like well you got to get a
cup of coffee and you got to be heard
i'm tired yeah and you got to go ah
you're not the mind i'm the mind right
now you're going to sit here i'm going
to feed you
you're you're gonna get your coffee
you're gonna do all those things but
right now this is my time you're gonna
obey me right
so now the body's no longer the mind
you're the mind and so when it wants to
get up and you become aware of it and
return back to the present moment every
time you do that's a victory
and you're changing some aspect of
yourself so then
ask yourself i do this all the time
write down four thoughts
that you're going to stay conscious of
the whole day i can't it's too hard
you'd be surprised the moment you become
conscious of what those thoughts are how
unconscious you've been to them all day
you know for weeks on end write down
what you speak how you speak four things
you want to change how you act how do
you how do you act you complain you
blame you make excuses you feel sorry
for yourself that's a victim
consciousness
what emotions do you live by is it
possible that you're so used to living
by guilt you don't even know it's guilt
it just feels like you
you allow your energy to drop become
conscious of those states of mind and
body and review them and say this is the
old self
then say
what thoughts do i want to fire and wire
in my brain
and start firing and wiring and start
feeling it what behaviors will i
demonstrate today what choices will i
make one day one lifetime
just like you did rehearse them
rehearse the whole entire thing begin to
install the neurological hardware in
your brain and if you keep installing it
the hardware is going to become a
software program and you start thinking
and acting that way and then here's a
tough part
can you teach your body emotionally
what your future is going to feel like
before it's made manifest
and don't get up until you feel that way
now
practice that for a few days
and then see if you can stay in that
state and watch all of a sudden all
those weird doors start opening for you
synchronicities synchronicities whatever
they are number two
take up time at the end of your day
the end of your day before you lay down
and give thanks for your life and
feel gratitude and really teach your
body what it feels like the emotional
signature of gratitude gratitude means
you're getting something if i give you
something that's of value you would say
thank you because you would feel it
right so when you're receiving
you're giving thanks so gratitude is the
ultimate state of receiving
so then people only accept believe and
surrender to the thoughts equal to their
emotional state so if you're in a state
of gratitude
every thought is going to make it right
down into your body if you're saying i'm
i'm healthy i'm healthy i'm healthy i'm
wealthy and wealthy i'm wealthy and your
body's programmed the negativity it's
saying no you're not no you're not
knowing i thought it's going to stop
right here so as you elevate your state
there are about
1200
different chemical reactions that go on
in the body begin to restore and repair
the body in a state of gratitude
and so we've done the research to prove
that
10 minutes
and just feel it
with all of your heart that's it
third thing
and
very important
take time whenever it is
sit down close your eyes
and begin to just open your awareness
to the space around you and just sense
it and pay attention to it become more
aware of it the act of opening your
awareness begins to reduce the stress
hormones and creates more coherent
brainwave states i'm doing it right now
it's just a practice
it's just a practice
the more you do it
i want to explain something to you
that not many people really understand i
want to talk about the law of attraction
do you know that the law of attraction
is always working it's like the law of
gravity if i let this go it's going to
go down it's never going to go back up
it's going to go down that is the law of
gravity anything heavier than earth is
attracted towards the center of the
world well the law of attraction is
always working
now how does it work
well
i use a diagram
to explain the mind now let this circle
represent your mind
and let this little circle here
represent your body
now i want you to think of this for a
moment your body is a molecular
structure this is a massive energy and a
very high speed of vibration
if you looked at your body through a
microscope you'd see that energy dancing
right before your eyes and here's
something that'll keep you thinking for
the next 20 years when you move out of
it the body does not stop moving if you
go to a funeral parlor
and pick up the remains and look at it
you will see it moving and if it wasn't
moving how would it ever change the dust
you move into your body and you will
move up
and it's how you use your mind that's
going to dictate the vibration you're in
now stay with me
you have an imaginary line right across
here
and that separates the conscious mind
from the subconscious mind
now this subconscious mind has been
programmed
when you were a little baby this is the
way it was so just like this
subconscious mind wide open and
everything that was going on around it
went right in there
and all the energy that went in there
when you were just a little baby form
something called a paradigm
now a paradigm
is information it's a multitude of
habits you are the product of your
environment but prior to that you are
the product of a genetic strain that
goes back for generations now i'm going
to say that the paradigm is x type
energy
now you've got the ability here on a
conscious level to think
and you can think anything you want to
think
and as you think you build ideas
there's a power that's flowing into your
consciousness it never stops it flows to
and through you you can actually
photograph this power leaving you it
flows to and through you
now as it flows in you will start
thinking and you'll probably think x
type thoughts
therefore you're going to be in an x
type vibration
and that will produce
x type results now it's the results you
want to change
and to change the results you're going
to have to change what you attract
you see the thoughts that you think
control the vibration that you're in
vibration is nothing but an idea it's a
law of the universe everything vibrates
nothing rests we live in a notion of
motion and it's the thoughts that you're
thinking that you impress upon your
subconscious mind that control the
vibration the body's in and that
dictates how you act but it also
dictates what you attract
you attract energy that's in harmony
with you you attract people that are in
harmony with you you see everything
operates on frequencies there's an
infinite number of frequencies but you
and i operate on a frequency just like a
radio station does and the only music
you can attract is the music that is
tuned in to the vibration you're in
now it's the paradigm that has been
controlling the vibration
you can change your thinking
but that doesn't do anything you got to
change the paradigm
and if you don't change the paradigm
nothing happens
now
talking about paradigms is another
subject we'll do that at another time
but it's the thoughts that you think
that control the vibration you're in and
that dictates what you attract so if you
keep attracting what you don't want
understand this
it's the paradigm that's causing the
problem you can think a y type thought
which is totally different than the x
type conditioning it isn't going to go
anywhere
because when you go to get emotionally
involved and this is the emotional mind
when you go to get emotionally involved
with that y-type done the paradigm will
kick it out you know why it's so
uncomfortable
that's stepping out of the box that's
doing things different and we don't like
to do things different because it causes
a lot of discomfort
but understand this
the paradigm and the thinking control
the vibration you're in and the
vibration is going to dictate what you
attract
people that are in a poverty
consciousness will continue to attract
lack and limitation it has nothing to do
with this what's going on here this is
your educated mind and you could gather
all kinds of information have you ever
wondered why some people have such an
educated mind they have degrees coming
right off the end of their business card
but it doesn't show up in their results
why
paradigm
the law of attraction
you've got to change this
you've got to change the vibration
you're in and your whole world changes
listen
in 1961 a man gave me this book and he
said do exactly what i tell you he was
giving me y type ideas it caused an
enormous amount of discomfort but i did
exactly what he said and you know
something
my income went from
to 175 000 in a year and then i took it
over a million
it took me nine and a half years to
figure out what happened
this is what i'm showing you
watch this over and over and over again
there's a number of lessons in here when
the paradigms change your life changes
it's a beautiful concept it's an
absolutely phenomenal concept
now you know why you're getting the
results you're getting it has nothing to
do with your intellect your intellect
you can figure out how to do things
that doesn't mean you're going to do
them you'll hear people say i believe
that but their behavior would indicate
they've never even heard of it why
we believe something on a conscious
level on a subconscious level the
paradigm believes something else
there's a word called praxis praxis is
the integration of belief with behavior
we've got to take the beliefs that we
have consciously that we determine by
thinking
and plant them in the place of the old
belief see i used to believe that i
couldn't do anything better than i was
doing
i felt fortunate that i was on the fire
department
the idea of building a company that
operated all around the world furthest
thing from my mind
but you know something as i changed my
paradigm my whole world changed
that's what we do that's what it's all
about
you've got to change your paradigm if
you want to change your life now you can
study all you want if you don't gain an
understanding how to alter that program
and that's what the paradigm is it's a
program it's a multitude of concepts
that are fixed in your subconscious mind
that literally control your behavior
it's a beautiful concept
to understand
it's a terrible one if you don't
understand it because it literally
controls your life why do you think most
people go right through their life and
keep getting the same results year after
year after year
well
it's just the way it is and they don't
know we should be taught this in school
but we're not
how was the paradigm formed through the
repetition of information how's the
paradigm change repetition of
information
now let's suppose you're having a
difficult time with money
you find that you've got more going out
than coming in
you've got to change your concept about
money how do you do that through the
repetition of an idea that's where
affirmations comes in i'll give you one
i've been using for years
i am so happy and grateful now that
money comes to me in increasing
quantities through multiple sources on a
continuous basis i am so happy and
grateful now that money comes to me in
increasing quantities through multiple
sources on a continuous basis
you don't just say that once or twice
you've got to repeat that maybe a
thousand times a day every day for maybe
90 days and you'll start to change your
whole concept about money wealthy people
all have multiple sources of income
now i'm going to tell you what happened
to me
i drove around with a battery operated
record player
and a long playing record
and i played it over and over again
every day for probably a couple of years
this was so totally illogical it was
behavior everybody thought i was losing
it and i'm reading the same book every
day think and grow rich as a matter of
fact i'm still reading the same book
and it was the repetition
of earl nightingale's information and
the book that changed the paradigm i
didn't know what i was doing i didn't
understand what i was doing but i did it
do you know i had a man come up to me
in the waldorf hotel in new york the
waldorf astoria
at the end of a three-day program and he
said bob i really want to thank you for
what you've just given to me he said for
the first time in my life i've
understood how i accomplished what i did
i said what did you do he said i won the
gold medal in the decathlon in the
olympics in melbourne australia in 1957
that's right
milt campbell and he said i never
understood how he did it he said the
next time you run a seminar i want to
bring my boys and he did milt and i
became great friends in fact milt has a
key to our house he can come stay there
anytime he wants i live in toronto he's
in new
jersey but here was the top athlete the
world a very best athlete in the world
he didn't understand how he got there
most people that are very accomplished
cannot tell you why they are that's why
they are they've rewritten the program
they changed the paradigm they might not
have understood how they did it but they
did it
that's what our company is all about we
teach people how to change paradigms i
want to thank you for watching this
but i'm going to ask you to share it
with other people
share it with them say come and watch
this start a rapport build a rapport
with people you know
it's a great way to live
and this is great information to
understand
thanks for listening it's bob proctor i
enjoy sharing it with you
when i get my new car i get my new house
i get my new relationship
then i'm gonna feel so great
now that well then they're back to the
program waiting for it to happen
for them to feel the emotion they're
believing their outer world has to
change in order for them to feel better
there's there's no
effect of drawing the experience to you
with that way
so
the person has to use those tools to get
them into the emotional state
for them to feel like it's already
happened now think about this
if you get up from
a creative process
and you feel grateful you feel a love
for life you feel a joy for existence
you feel a passion
uh
to
for the moment
uh
you will not be looking for your future
because you'll feel like it's already
happened
it's the moment that we start feeling
those self-limiting emotions that we
feel separation and then we start
looking for it again well then if you're
waiting you're not creating you're
you're in separation again so then yeah
so then
whatever it takes for you to move into a
state of being and what is a state of
being
thoughts are the vocabulary of the brain
feelings are the vocabulary of your body
how you think and how you feel creates
your state of being so then if you wake
up in the morning and you
come come back to your senses with a
clean slate and you say i don't feel
anything you say well let me start
thinking about all the problems in my
life well all those problems are
connected to different people or
different objects of things at different
times and places the moment you remember
your problems a memory is a record of
the past you're thinking in the past
every one of those problems has an
emotion associated with them so all of a
sudden you start feeling unhappy you
start feeling bitter you start feeling
frustrated so now your body's in the
past so then most people then
create a state of being that's connected
to their past and if they're in the
familiar past
then they are going to crave the
predictable future and they're going to
fall back into routine
so then
we want people then to get very clear on
that vision of their future however they
do it and begin to combine that clear
intention with an elevated emotion and
the stronger the emotion they feel
from the vision they're creating the
more altered they feel inside of them
the more they're going to pay attention
to the pictures in their mind and now
they're remembering their future and
biologically it's exactly the same as
remembering your past in fact if you're
not being defined by a vision in the
future it means you're making your past
more real than your future you're
falling in love with your past you're
more in love with your past than you are
with your future that you're believing
in your past more than you're believing
in your future when you get to that
moment
where you have that feeling
that's your compass
because that feeling is going to drive
your behaviors it's going to drive more
of those thoughts and when you feel that
feeling and it's visceral
no person
no thing no experience will stand in the
way between you and that vision and and
you will be initiated in by the universe
into wealth you will be initiated into
health you'll be initiated into freedom
those people all those people that have
healed themselves of all those different
health conditions
they are so humble
and so happy and they feel so great
that they would never trade this feeling
because of what you thought of them they
they've they've left that program behind
a long time ago they actually don't care
how you think of them they they actually
are so happy with themselves
that they are no longer dependent on
anything outside of them now i think
that's a really important moment because
that's the moment we give people
permission in our lives to do the same
right and i think that more and more
people are beginning to figure that out
uh as they being defined by a vision of
the future
then you're left with the old memories
of the past and you will be predictable
in your life
and if you wake up in the morning and
you're not being defined by a vision in
the future as you see the same people
and you go to the same places and you do
the exact same thing at the exact same
time
it's no longer that your personality is
creating your personal reality now your
personal reality is affecting or
creating your personality your
environment is really controlling how
you think and feel unconsciously because
every person everything every place
every experience has a neurological
network in your brain
every experience that you have with
every person produces an emotion so some
people will use their boss to reaffirm
their addiction to judgment they'll use
their enemy to reaffirm their addiction
to hatred they'll use their friends to
reaffirm their addiction to suffering so
now they need the outer world to feel
something
so
to change then
is to be greater than your environment
to be greater than the conditions in
your world and the environment is that
seductive
so then
why is meditation the tool well
let's sit down let's close our eyes
let's disconnect
from your outer environment so if you're
seeing less things there's less
stimulation going to your brain if
you're playing soft music or you have
ear plugs in less sensory information
coming to your brain so you're
disconnecting from your environment if
you can sit your body down we have a
huge frontal lobe and it's 40 of our
entire brain
and most people
when they have a thought they just think
that that's the truth and i think one of
my greatest
realizations in my own journey was
just because you have a thought doesn't
necessarily mean it's true
so if you think 60 to 70 000 thoughts in
one day and we do and 90 of those
thoughts are the same thoughts as the
day before and you believe that your
thoughts have something to do with your
destiny your life's not going to change
very much because the same thought leads
to the same choice the same choice leads
to the same behavior the same behavior
creates the same experience and the same
experience produces the same emotion and
so then
the act of becoming conscious of this
process to to begin to become more aware
of how you think how you act and how you
feel it's called metacognition and so
then
why is that important because the more
conscious
you become of those unconscious states
of mind and body
the less likely you're going to go
unconscious during the day and that
thought
is not going to slip by your awareness
unchecked
because you're
it means to know thyself and the word
meditation means to become familiar with
so as you become familiar with the
thoughts the behaviors and the emotions
of the old self you're retiring that old
self as you fire and wire new thoughts
and condition the body into a new
emotional state if you do that enough
times it'll begin to become familiar to
you so
it's so important
just like a garden if you're planting a
garden you've got to get rid of the
weeds
you got to take the plants from the past
year and you got to pull them out the
rocks that sift to the top that are like
our emotional blocks they have to be
removed the soil has to be tenderized
and broken down we have to we have to
make room to plant a new garden so
primarily we learn the most about
ourselves and others when we're
uncomfortable because the moment you
move into that uncomfortable state
normally a program jumps in when that
program jumps in it's because a person
doesn't want to be in the present moment
and engage it consciously
so when you teach people how to do that
with a meditative process
it turns out that when they're in their
life
they're less likely to emotionally react
they're less likely to be so rigid and
believe the thoughts they were thinking
they're more aware of when they go
unconscious back into a habit and that
is what starts the process of change
and so we have to unlearn before we
relearn we have to break the habit of
the old self before we reinvent the new
self we have to prune synaptic
connections and sprout new connections
we have to unfire and unwire and re-fire
and rewire we have to unmemorize
emotions that are stored in the body
then recondition the body to a new mind
into a new motion like deprogram and
reprogram that's the act and it's a
two-step process first of all every time
we have a thought we make a chemical and
and if you have
an unlimited thought you will feel
unlimited and if you have a
self-depreciating thought you'll feel
unworthy and your brain instantaneously
fires circuits
that signal another part of the brain to
release peptides or chemical messengers
that signal hormonal centers
and when we get that arousal from the
thought that we think
those thoughts sometimes weaken the
response weakens the physical body so
it turns out that
the emotions that are created from the
thoughts are the signaling mechanisms of
the body thoughts of the language of the
brain and feelings are the language of
the body and how we think and how we
feel uh creates our state of being
so it turns out that the thoughts based
in the stress hormones
based in survival those are the thoughts
that begin to push the genetic buttons
that create disease in other words
a person wakes up in the morning
and the brain is a record of the past
the first thing they do when they wake
up in the morning is they start thinking
about their problems
and those problems are memories that are
etched in the brain that are connected
to certain people certain objects
certain things at certain times and
places so if you believe that your
thoughts have something to do with your
destiny the moment you think about your
problems you're thinking in the past
right
now every one of those problems has an
emotion associated with them because
we've experienced them so the moment you
remember your problems
now you feel unhappy now you feel
anxious now you feel fear
so the moment we feel those emotions it
takes a thought and a feeling
a memory or an image an emotion
a stimulus and a response and we start
conditioning the body emotionally into
the past now the body
is so objective
that it doesn't know the difference
between the real life experience that's
creating that emotion
and the emotion that person's
fabricating by thought alone the body's
believing it's in that environmental
condition
so if the environment signals the gene
and that's the truth
and the end product of an experiences in
the environment is an emotion
we're signaling the same genes and genes
make proteins and if you keep signaling
the same genes you start down regulating
the gene to make cheaper proteins and
the body begins to break down now that's
an unconscious process so what goes
along with that is the moment the person
feels that emotion of unhappiness or
whatever it is
the brain checks in with the body and
says yeah you're feeling pretty
miserable you're suffering and we tend
to generate more thoughts equal to the
feeling that we have
and so then we get caught in this loop
of thinking and feeling so if we can't
think
greater than how we feel
our feelings have become the means of
thinking
then we're thinking in the past
right
and so we call that
the familiar past and then a person gets
going in the day and they start thinking
oh i gotta see this person i gotta go to
that meeting i hate doing this and now
they get in their routine
and a habit is a redundant set of
automatic unconscious thoughts behaviors
and emotions that's acquired through
repetition
a habit is when you've done something so
many times that the body now knows how
to do it better than the mind
so now the person running through the
same routine every single day is on
autopilot and their body's now dragging
them
into a predictable future based on what
they did in the past and they've lost
their free will
to a set of programs right so now you
have the familiar past and you have the
predictable future those are knowns
so the only place then reasonably where
the unknown exists
is the sweet spot of the generous
present moment that is when the body and
mind are free from those conditions so
along with those emotions that influence
the same thoughts
people start becoming more judgmental
they start becoming more impatient they
start becoming more entitled
they start getting more afraid more
anxious more depressed and now the body
is literally being depleted
of energy because it's believing that
it's living in an emergency situation
and in emergency you tap all of the
body's resources for some threat whether
it's real or imagined
and so then when you're releasing all of
these chemicals we are literally drawing
the body's life force and turning it
into chemistry and so for the short term
that's cool but the arousal that's
created from those stress hormones
is a rush of energy
and so then people use the problems
and the conditions in their life to
reaffirm their conditioning or their
addiction to that emotion
and in a sense they become addicted to
the life they don't even like
and this is why change is so hard
so then when a person makes up their
mind to change and they say okay i'm not
going to say i can't i'm not going to
judge another person i'm not going to
blame i'm not going to complain i'm not
going to make excuses i'm not going to
be a victim i'm not going to talk trash
about anybody i'm just going to stop
well that works out really well for the
first couple hours
and the bodies saying you're out of
schedule you normally at eight in the
morning you're getting traffic and
you're angry then at 11 o'clock you
check your emails and you're really
judgmental and frustrated the body's
saying well you've been doing this for
the last 20 years you're just going to
stop today so now the body which has
been conditioned emotionally to be the
mind wants to return back to its
familiar territory to the known
so the body starts influencing the mind
and it says you know come on
this is a good time to judge that come
on this is a good time to suffer it's
your ex's fault it's it's your it's the
government's fault it's uh
you know it's the weather what the news
whatever it is and if we
accept
believe and surrender to that thought
without analyzing it it slips by and it
begins to program the autonomic nervous
system to make those pharmacy of
chemicals
and so
that's when the person makes the same
choice
does the same thing
creates the same experience just for
that familiar feeling okay i'll complain
just so i can feel suffering then
they'd rather
be unhappy
and step into the unknown to step into
possibility and the hardest part about
that process
first of all is not making the same
choice as you did day before
and here's the payoff
you got to stay conscious
and not go unconscious and it turns out
that 95 of the time we're unconscious so
if you're going to stay conscious then
there's an element that also requires a
certain amount of awareness or energy
and you got to step outside of that
unconscious state so the thoughts that
they're thinking
are slipping by their awareness
unnoticed because they're hardwired in
their brain because they've been saying
i can't it's too hard my life will never
change it's someone else's fault those
thoughts have consequences in the body
so then if a person then becomes
conscious
of those unconscious thoughts becomes
aware of how they speak and how they act
and they notice
how they're feeling they're no longer
the program they're the consciousness
outside the program and that's the first
step to change so
there are
when you when you're distracted by your
environment and you got your cell phone
and you're tweeting and you're
instagramming and facebooking whatever
people do you're distracted by that
feeling
but i now know that if you take a person
and you say okay close your eyes
sit in the in the silence of any
external stimulation remove the
environment sit your body down like an
animal body is the animal tell it to
stay i'm gonna feed you
you can check your cell phone you can
shower you can have your coffee but when
i say
and so then here comes the challenge
right so and and then
if you say then you're not going to live
in the familiar future familiar past or
predictable future you're not going to
think about how long you've been
meditating what you got to do you you
labor
uh for that present moment
people think when they do this that
they're doing something wrong because
there's such discomfort that comes with
it
but they're in the unknown they're
actually doing it right people say i
think i'm meditating wrong i always say
oh no no no you're doing it right
because when you notice that your body
wants to get up and check your cell
phone or have a cup of coffee and you
become aware that it's on autopilot and
wants to do that and you say
come on over here
and you return it back to the present
moment
you're executing a will now
that's greater than the program and if
the person
wants to just get angry while they're
sitting there there's an arousal and
they notice the body is amping up and
revving up and they settle it back down
now they're telling the body it's no
longer the mind
that they're the mind now we've
researched this
and it's tedious
in the beginning at first because david
is fighting goliath
but if you keep practicing it just like
training an animal sooner or later the
body acquiesces sooner or later the body
is trained to a new mind and when that
happens
there's a liberation of energy the body
goes from particle to wave from matter
to energy and there goes that emotion
literally liberated from body as energy
so the person who has the strong emotion
to some circumstance in their life
and they're
they're working and lowering the volume
of that emotion the more they lower the
volume of that emotion the more they're
going to take their attention off that
person and problem and they're going to
take their power back there's going to
be a break
in their attention from that
circumstance and now they build their
own field and now there's energy to heal
now there's energy to create a new life
now there's energy for the mystical
moment because they've overcome their
old personality self so
i think you know it's not like thinking
positively that's not the message it's
it's overcoming
overcoming overcoming overcoming until
we become somebody else and when that
occurs and the person starts thinking
differently
and they start acting differently
and they start feeling differently
they're a new personality and they they
start seeing those synchronicities and
serendipities now
crossing that river of change
the creative process now gets exciting
because what thoughts do you want to
fire in wire in your brain what kind of
attention and intention when i'm going
through change in my life or i have a
specific outcome that i want to create i
love to get up early in the morning
that's my time i'm a 4 30 in the morning
guy because
that's my time the rest of the day i'm
serving but
i love getting up early and changing and
working and having some time to myself
and i believe that when i invest in
myself i invest in my future
and that time in my in my morning nobody
bothers me because that's my time
and because of brain waves and brain
chemistry
the door between the conscious mind and
the subconscious mind is more open
and so if i get up early and i'm kind of
between theta and alpha i don't have to
work as hard i'm not thinking i just
kind of relax into the moment
in the evening i always ask myself how
did i do
how was one lifetime in one day where
did i fall from grace what happened
and so
then when i look at seeing how i reacted
to someone or something or i made the
choice that i could have made a better
choice i naturally and we all do this
begin to think well if the same
situation happened again how would i do
it differently
and that's the act of beginning to come
up with a new plan
the act of rehearsing it in your mind
begins to install the circuits in your
brain priming your brain so that when
the next experience happens you could
modify your behavior to do a better job
in life that's called plasticity
so
it doesn't matter for me what meditation
i do any longer i like to just get up in
a new state of being people say to me
hey um
i miss my meditation today like i'm
supposed to go like this or something
and i say to them
eyes open our eyes closed
you know my eyes open our eyes closed
you know when you're passionate about
something
you know when people can't get up in the
morning and they can't get out of bed
i'm going to tell you why
because they can predict the feeling of
everything that's going to happen in
their life and their bodies resigned to
the familiar it says oh another mundane
day but remember when you were a kid and
you were going on a field trip
what happened then
you were up and dressed and ready to go
before your parents were up you know why
because you knew something unexpected
was going to happen that's how we should
live our lives waking up with the
understanding to expect the unexpected
and something unusual should happen in
our life as a result of our efforts and
it's just those beginning moments where
it begins to happen that we begin to
prove to ourselves how powerful we
really are so take time in the morning
in the evening and the rest of the day
check in with yourself at certain times
to see if you're still in that energy
and if you're not excuse yourself for a
second raise your energy and step back
into your life if you keep doing that
over and over again
you'll become less frustrated less
impatient less judgmental it'll just
become something of the past and you'll
be someone else newtonian world is all
about the predictable it's all about
predicting a future but the quantum
model of reality is is about causing an
effect the moment you start feeling
abundant and worthy you are generating
wealth the moment you're empowered and
feel it you're beginning to step towards
your success the moment you start
feeling whole
your healing begins and when you love
yourself and you love all of life you'll
create an equal and now you're causing
an effect
and i think that's the
difference between living as a victim
in your world saying i am this way
because of this person or that thing or
this experience they made me think and
feel this way
when you switch that around you become a
creator of your world and you start
saying my thinking and my feeling is
changing an outcome in my life and now
that's a whole different game and we
start believing more that we're creators
of reality how do we then go from that
like mechanistically
to begin this visualization process of
something that's empowering it's me in a
different state it's my future self is
it meditation is it
what does that look like if you're not
being defined by a vision of the future
then you're left with the old memories
of the past and you will be predictable
in your life
and if you wake up in the morning and
you're not being defined by a vision in
the future as you see the same people
and you go to the same places and you do
the exact same thing at the exact same
time
it's no longer that your personality is
creating your personal reality now your
personal reality is affecting or
creating your personality your
environment is really controlling how
you think and feel unconsciously because
every person everything every place
every experience has a neurological
network in your brain
every experience that you have with
every person produces an emotion so some
people will use their boss to reaffirm
their addiction to judgment they'll use
their enemy to reaffirm their addiction
to hatred they'll use their friends to
reaffirm their addiction to suffering so
now
they need the outer world to feel
something
so
to change then is to be greater than
your environment to be greater than the
conditions in your world in the
environment is that seductive
so then why is meditation the tool well
let's sit down let's close our eyes
let's disconnect
from your outer environment so if you're
seeing less things there's less
stimulation going to your brain if
you're playing soft music or you have
ear plugs in less sensory information
coming to your brain so you're
disconnecting from your environment if
you can sit your body down
and tell it to stay like an animal stay
right here i'm gonna feed you when we're
done you can get up and check your
emails you can do all your texts but
right now you're gonna sit there and
obey me
so then
when you do that properly and you're not
eating anything or smelling anything or
tasting anything you're not up
experiencing and feeling anything you
would have to agree with me that you're
being defined by a thought right
so when the body wants to go back to its
emotional past
and you become aware that your attention
is on that emotion and where you place
your attention is where you place your
energy you're siphoning your energy out
of the present moment into the past and
you become aware of that
and you settle your body back down in
the present moment because it's saying
well it's eight o'clock you normally get
upset because you're in traffic around
this time and here you are sitting and
we're used to feeling anger and you're
off schedule oh it's 11 o'clock and
usually check your emails and judge
everybody well the body's looking for
that that predictable chemical state
every time you become aware that you're
doing that and your body is craving
those emotions and you settle it back
down into the present moment you're
telling the body
it's no longer the mind that you're the
mind and now your will
is getting greater than the program and
if you keep doing this over and over
again over and over again over and over
again just like training a stallion
or a dog it's just gonna say
i'm gonna sit and the moment that
happens when the body's no longer the
mind when it finally surrenders
there's a liberation of energy
we go from particle to wave from matter
to energy and we free ourselves from the
chains of those emotions that keep us in
the in the familiar past and we've seen
this thousands of times in fact we can
actually predict it now on a brain scan
the law of attraction definitely works
most people just get it wrong most
people only focus on the thinking part
and not the most important part which is
the action right law of attraction it's
the last five letters that matter a c t
i o a c t i o n six the last six letters
that matter action action action
thinking about it alone is not enough so
it's the two parts you get an idea you
want something into your life you want
to manifest something amazing you want
success in your business you want a
happy relationship awesome you want to
speak on giant stages whatever the thing
is that you want in your life awesome
you have a vision board amazing just the
fact that you're thinking about it
and believing in it is already a big
step ahead of where most people are most
people live in a negative zone most
people feel like their life is hopeless
that they can't make a change that
they're stuck where they are and guess
what happens they stay exactly stuck
where they are right what you focus on
ends up becoming your reality so yes
you're going to focus on your new goal
your new habit the new thing that you
want into your life amazing you believe
that it's possible amazing you're
putting up a vision board with it on
your wall amazing you're researching and
watching videos like this every day
amazing that's great that's the first
starting point but nothing happens until
you take action
nothing happens until you take action
thinking alone is not enough
again it puts you ahead of most of the
most of the world puts you way ahead of
them but you're still just going to be
this super smart super ambitious person
sitting at home not achieving your goals
you have to do something i look at my
youtube channel as an example uh my main
channel i want to get the 10 million
subscribers that's my next goal right we
hit one we hit two i gotta hit ten
uh at the rate that we're growing it's
not fast enough like it's going to take
me way too many years to make it happen
so i need to apply more pressure against
it so
part of what i look at every day now in
my morning routine is i want to hit my
goal i want to get 10 million
subscribers on my youtube channel right
i want to be you know one of the first
uh thought leaders experts business
person to have 10 million subscribers on
a youtube channel it's my next goal
great writing that down every day
doesn't make sure that it's going to
happen what am i doing
right writing it down can lead to
thoughts that then lead to action but
what am i actually doing well i'll tell
you what i'm doing now
one of the biggest things i'm working on
now big new initiative for my team is
i've got 6 000 public videos on my main
channel and
i told my team
this week i want to go back and update
all of the thumbnails and all of the
titles across all my videos
that's a lot of videos right that's 6
thousand videos imagine doing split
tests on all of those videos
i asked for ten a day and so two key
people on my team are working together
to come up with what the title is gonna
be and then the other one's doing the
graphic design to create the thumbnails
maybe it works the first time but maybe
it doesn't
and it's a big ambitious project if you
think about it we got 6000 videos 10
videos a day
you know in a year if we did it for 10
videos every day we're just over half of
those videos assuming that they all work
out which they won't
so this is our test and if it works
awesome i might have that become
somebody's full-time job so that we can
do 20 slit tests a day 40 split tests a
day 100 split desks a day i don't know
but it's happening to action right so it
starts with the idea if you have the
idea but you're not taking action you
won't get results if you just have the
action but you have no idea you're
running around with a chicken with your
head cut off you're you're going in
circles without any clear direction
most people
think too much and don't do enough
that's most people some people do too
much and don't think enough some people
need more planning but in general most
people are over planners and so watching
this video alone is not enough
it's a great start it might boost your
motivation it might give you an idea to
go off and try watching my content
watching dan lok's content alone is not
enough it's the essential first piece of
the ingredient it's it's essential
surrounding yourself with people who
build you up who make you believe who
give you ideas you can act on that allow
you to feel like your goals are are
possible that your dreams are within
reach is super important i do it every
day it's why i create all these channels
i think you should too you'll notice a
difference in how you think every single
day if you are creating content and
consuming content that builds you up
but then you still have to go take the
second step
it's why after every video i have a
question today or i have a three
three-point landing question because i
want you to take action you need to
teach yourself that after every video
you watch up to every podcast you listen
to after every book that you read
but that's not enough you have to do
something about it i'd rather you watch
fewer videos read fewer books listen to
fewer podcasts consume less
if you're taking action on the ideas
that come to you because most people are
just professional
consumers
and it's great that you're consuming
educational content because most people
are just consuming stupid content right
you hate your lives you go watch netflix
all day when you get home for five hours
and then go to sleep right you're a
professional consumer but you're
consuming
uh wasteful content just entertaining
content
so you've already taken a step above
right you're consuming educational
content that's the next step you're
consuming educational content amazing
but still that alone is not enough what
separates the people go off and achieve
their dreams from the ones who just have
things on a vision board is that last
step of taking action so you're not
allowed anymore you're new standards
you're raising your standards for
yourself you are not allowed anymore to
watch a video to read a book to listen
to a podcast to consume anything without
taking some kind of immediate action
towards it immediate action immediate
action it may not be the big thing
if you want to hit a million subscribers
on your youtube channel great what's
immediate action film a video today make
an improvement to your thumbnail today
reach out for an interview for someone
today right immediate action teach
yourself that as soon as you get an idea
you do something about it because that's
the only thing that you're missing the
only thing that you're missing is
momentum if you're watching this channel
you believe in your talent you know
you're capable of more you've got big
goals big ambitions big dreams for
yourself the only thing you're missing
is momentum so to activate the law of
attraction pay attention to the last six
letters action and start doing something
about it when you have a goal in your
head it's not even a goal it's a fantasy
it's a dream
when you have a book like this you can
call it your goal book and you write out
your goals and you go through i'm just
about to take you through bit by bit
stage by stage you go back to that but
you can look at it you can touch it you
can just make it real
so remember if you do not write out your
goals as a plan
and write out how to accomplish them you
don't have a goal you have a wish you
have a dream you have a daydream
if you want to go get a pen get a nice
little book like this you can do on your
phone too you can make a document in
your computer
and be prepared to make your goals real
so let's
start now
get your book pause this if you need to
go and find one create one and i want
you to pick a goal and do not even start
with i want to lose five pounds i want
more money these are what i call wishy
washy goals no
if you can make your goals real you
might as well make them huge big
enormous phenomenal
so if you say well i want more money
that's my good oh hang on a minute
hey i got ten dollars here there you go
you go well that's not my goal but you
said
i want more money and i learned this
when i used to work with women who were
infertile that come and go you know i
just want to be pregnant i want to be
pregnant so bad
if i was just pregnant i go well
as i look at your notes you've been
pregnant six times i know i keep
miscarrying
so being pregnant is not your goal is it
what
isn't your goal to carry to full term a
healthy robust bouncing baby to deliver
a perfect baby to be a great mum yeah
that's my goal
why don't you say that
because you can be pregnant lots of
times and never have a baby or you can
say my goal
is to have a perfect baby how about this
my goal is to get lots of attention for
what a nervous twitch
explosive gas that will give you
attention but that's not what you want
is it nobody wants explosive gas
so let's start with a big goal pause if
you need to
take some time open your book
and write out a big goal now you can
have a career goal on whatever i'm going
to have my own company create my own
business invent something you can have a
relationship goal my relationship is
wonderful we grow
in loving and respecting each other and
you can have a health goal
but i want you to pick one only one not
three not five not in one goal it can be
career
it can be health
it can be love pick one goal
and then i want you to decide why you
want that goal so much so the first
thing is i have a goal
i want to have my own business that's my
goal and now you're going to go to a
next page and write out why
do you want to have your own business so
much and the more reasoned you can write
out why the more likely
you will make that goal real so write
down why write down as many wise as you
can and remember
you can come back any time to this and
think oh i've thought of another y and
another y so leave plenty of space
take your time and when you've done your
whys go to another page and write out
who
will benefit from you achieving that
goal of course you will but who
who will benefit for instance if you
have your own business
you will employ people who will benefit
maybe your kids will go to private
school maybe your business will allow
you to help your partner have their
business
the more people who will benefit from
you achieving your goal
the more reasons you have to achieve
that goal so write out who will benefit
from you
achieving a who
how and why will they benefit you're
going to buy
your mama house put your niece and
nephew through private school did you
think of your mind as like the genie
in the bottle that says your wish is my
command
and i want you to understand that every
thought you think
and every word you say is a blueprint
that your mind body and psyche must make
real so when you write out your goals
don't say i wish
i could be rich
i long to be in a loving relationship
write it as if it's already happening i
am
a millionaire i am in a loving
relationship that doesn't make sense it
does make sense because your mind only
works in the present tense
when you say next year i'll have a
bikini body it doesn't know what next
year is
and so you must write your goals in the
present tense i am i always i have i do
this new page is about your discipline
how many hours a day are you going to
spend
working on your goal
how often are you going to come back to
this book and look at it i want you to
write out i
am
i
always i have i do and i want you to
fill that in
you see the best goal in the world will
not work if you don't work and many
people fail at this point they write out
a goal
my goal is to be a millionaire my goal
is to be famous my goal is to be wildly
in love and i think that's it
it's not it if you want to be madly in
love
write all the reasons why but then you
have got to
put yourself in front of the kind of
person you want to share your life with
if you want to start your own business
and you have a reason why you also need
to have the discipline to meet people
who will fund you sponsor you joint
venture with you
so i want you to really understand that
the best goal will not work if you don't
work you can have the start point
but you have to keep doing many of the
most successful people ever say well you
know i had a goal
luther vandross had a goal
to be a rock star
and people said well you're an overnight
success he went i don't think so you
know i sang jingles for kfc for 12 years
that's a long night 12 years and people
said but luther you're singing on
television that's cool you get paid a
lot of money for kfc he said yeah but
it's not my goal
and he stuck it out and many people have
got so close to success
and had to keep going and you have to
keep going so
look at your discipline and decide you
will give more to your goal give even
more
work on it look at it write it out think
about it talk about it you must be
prepared to give so much to your goal
in fact you must be prepared to be
unstoppable
in the pursuit of your goal let's talk
about manifesting
we are always manifesting
we're always attracting to us what we
believe
the energy that we put out the thoughts
that we have so when we're in a story of
something that we do want we feel good
about it we put out an energy to the
world that says i'm a yes for that and
then the universe responds by bringing
it to us
but we're also putting out vibes and
stories and thoughts and beliefs for
things that we don't want and that
energy is attracting towards us what we
don't want there are four major blocks
to your manifesting power the first one
is the manic manifester this is the
person who has all the self-help books
next to their bed they're repeating
positive affirmations they're meditating
they're constantly looking at a vision
board they're telling all their friends
what they desire but they're doing it
with an energy that's needy and frantic
and that energy is what attracts so
while they think that they're doing all
the right things their energy and their
belief systems and their vibration are
not aligned with what they desire and
this is a major block to your
manifesting power the next block is the
pushing manifester the pushy manifestor
believes that if they're not over
working that nothing will happen for
them
the harder i push the more i'll achieve
that is really a big block to our
manifesting power because when we're in
that pushy vibration and we're trying to
force something to happen we're not
receptive we're not in a place of
allowing and we are telling the universe
what our list is but we're not allowing
the universe to give to us what is of
the highest good
then there's the fearful manifesto fear
is an epidemic we are constantly plagued
by fear throughout our day the second
that we turn on the news the moment we
wake up in the morning the story goes on
repeat the loop of all the things that
are not working we have 60 000 thoughts
a day and the majority of them are the
same thought repeated over and over and
over again and all those fear-based
thoughts block us from our attracting
power so when we're stuck in fear we are
majorly blocking what we want by staying
stuck in the story of what we don't want
and the final block is the judgmental
manifesto
and this is the person who's comparing
themselves to others very jealous
talking negatively about other people in
some ways talking negatively to
themselves about themselves and that
judgment is a form of separation
when we're judging we're separating
ourselves from others but we're also
separating ourselves from our true
nature our true nature is a sense of
feeling interconnected and when we are
in a state of judgment
we block that connection
[Music]
how have these
different blocks held you back from
stepping into the person that you want
to be and attracting what you want into
your life let's start with addressing
the manic manifesto your job right now
is to really just let go and allow you
can keep meditating and you can keep
putting your vision board together and
you can continue to affirm what you
desire but check in with your energy see
how that energy may be frantic and manic
and in those moments take a deep breath
release it you can even use the
affirmation
i desire this now and i give it over to
the universe to present it to me
let it go allow and surrender
to clear the block of the pushy
manifestor it's important to start to
accept that you are supported far beyond
your wildest imagination and when you
meditate and you relax and you tune in
through your stillness you can start to
feel a sense of a presence beyond your
own and that presence is the presence of
love within you and around you
now if you identify as a fearful
manifester working through your fears a
lot easier than we think
the simple shift that begins this
healing of our fear is to just witness
it just look at it just call it by its
name when we look at it witness it and
call it out we defuse it
and the final block is a judgmental
manifesto start to want for others what
you want for yourself
start to see in others that their
greatness is a reflection of your own
but what you want a full manifesto you
have to meet the vibration you can't be
above or below it it's just what i was
talking about negative energy
positive energy in order to draw the
thing to you that you want to come you
can't want it so much that you fear that
you won't get it you have to want it so
in order for me to be on your vision
board you must have put it there and
then you let it go yes and then you
weren't thinking about it every day
every day every day because you can't it
doesn't come to you that way you have to
do it and you have to put it and you
have to meet that vibration you prepare
yourself to be there and ready when it
shows up and you were julie said you
were there if you are caught and
thinking negatively about the world and
about yourself this is so important what
would change inside of you if you looked
around
and you wrote down five things that
you're grateful for about the world now
this for me
is part of the secret to the law of
attraction it's the foundation is
gratitude it's your way of being must be
grateful in order to attract new things
there's so many things in my life that i
should not have attracted
because i didn't have the skills because
i didn't have the tools because i didn't
have the education because i didn't have
the money because i didn't have the
resources
so many things that i shouldn't have
attracted but because i had the
foundation of gratitude
passion joy curiosity those things
started to come to me and they can come
to you as well if you come from that
place of gratitude as your foundation
so you want to think about what are
these things that are important to me in
my life you know it can be simple things
it could be like this cup of coffee that
i have right now can be that i have a
roof over my head that i've got quality
friends that i'm healthy
you know that i'm walking in nature
today it doesn't have to be
some grandiose thing that's happened to
you to be grateful for i'm so grateful
for these little present moments
with people that i care about to spend
an hour on the beach to go for a walk
with a friend to have a good
conversation with someone and talk about
something i'm going through for me
that's just as meaningful
the moments in between the big moments
are just as meaningful so write down
these things or think about these things
this is something i embed in my daily
life when i wake up i think about what
i'm grateful for when i go to sleep i i
think about and reflect on the things
i'm grateful for from that day and it's
just my way of being for as much as i
can now i'm not perfect i make mistakes
and there's some times i'm negative
but it's something that i try to really
focus on as much as possible so instead
of saying that you're not enough that
you don't deserve success what if you
looked in the mirror on a daily basis i
dare you to look in the mirror on a
daily basis and say i am enough and i do
deserve
the results that i want to create in my
life because i show up because i'm
consistent because i work hard because i
care about my work
if you looked in the mirror and you did
this consistently for 30 days and you
actually
use the word action in attraction and
you put it into practice on a daily
basis towards that growth
i'd be amazed to see what you attract
and what you manifest in your life
manifesting is acquiring the experience
of what it is that you want to feel and
being and living and believing in that
experience and then allowing that
experience to come into form sometimes
we manifest things far beyond our
wildest dreams so sometimes if we have a
vision of something it happens in a far
greater way so we want to stay open yep
so we can say i want that macbook air
but maybe we get that macbook air that's
a little bit bigger than we thought yeah
or maybe it comes with an extra little
gift yeah but allowing ourselves to be
open this or something more manifesting
is very creative it is the process of
using your power energy and being in
that presence of your high-powered
energy and allowing that energy to
co-create with the energy that's around
you so you're vibrating at a high
frequency i'm vibrating at high
frequency we've done a lot of work we've
cleaned up a lot of our own crap we
believe in ourselves today and that that
energy of believing in ourselves has
attracted us together today and brought
us into this space where we together are
co-creating and teaching if i hadn't
cleaned up my side of the street and if
i didn't believe in myself the way i do
i would never have manifested being on
marietv miracles occur naturally and
when they're not occurring something has
gone wrong
that's interesting it's a good one right
so what happens is that that
synchronicity that flow that effortless
action that just sort of allowing oh i
was thinking about that and it just
showed up that's how life is supposed to
be
we get in the way our negative belief
systems our fears our anxiety our our
anger towards the past that future
tripping and projecting all of that
energy gets in the way of allowing all
of the miracles to occur naturally so
the first type of manifestation is to
get very very clear and you know if
we're not clear about what we desire
then we can call in some really funky
stuff you must be clear because if you
are unclear you'll start to call in some
things that are not really what you want
you'll be confused uh the other piece is
that once you're clear you can also then
get clear about all the ways that you
don't believe all of the limiting
beliefs all the negativity that might be
blocking you
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you're special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to learn the real secret to making
the law of attraction work check the
video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there what is the greatest
ideal of myself that i can be today you
ask yourself that question now listen
your body's going to go like well we got
to get a cup of coffee and you got
tired yeah and you gotta go